Today, we're going to be speaking with Chris
Smalls, who is a former Amazon employee who
has become a leader of the e-commerce and
labor rights movement.
Chris is going to tell us about his workforce
and his subsequent firing from Amazon.
Now, of course, we haven't been able to independently
confirm Chris's story, but it is a compelling
one.
And I am more than open to having someone
from Amazon on to talk to us about the things
that Chris is going to tell us.
Chris, you have a background that started
similar to mine, which is your background
is in retail.
I worked at the now defunct Circuit City when
I was much younger.
You worked at Wal-Mart and Target.
But let's talk a little bit about your work
for for Amazon.
How did you come to work at Amazon?
I started working in Amazon back in twenty
fifteen.
I came in entry level.
I came from before Amazon.
I was working at a grocery distribution warehouse
overnight graveyard shift that was unionized.
But the union contract just wasn't what I
expected it to be.
So I thought I have a better opportunity.
At Amazon.
I opened up the first building in Carterton,
Jersey, EWR nine.
I stayed there for about two years and then
I transferred to Middle to Connecticut.
And then my last facility was JFK, Staten
Island.
So I've been with the company for almost four
and a half years.
And what was your day to day like?
What kind of roles were you in?
So when I became when I first got hired, I
was entry level, I was what they call a picker,
I my job was to pick custom items in a timely
manner within the hour, hourly rate of about
then it was about 250 items an hour.
Now is a lot more is about 400 now.
But I did that for about six or seven months.
And then I was promoted up to a process assistant
that I'm known as an assistant manager.
And I was in that position for the last four
years now as an assistant manager.
Were you supervising pickers?
Yes, I actually supervise in pickers and then
and expanded to a different operation, which
now I was in control of three different departments.
So picking counting and also Florelle.
So Floor Help was also a part of the department
as well.
OK, so many people in my audience have probably
seen the articles that talk about the conditions
for the pickers and they include things like
you're not allowed to go to the bathroom and
there's this constant pressure to pick more
and more and more and the conditions are bad
and your breaks are monitored down to the
minute.
Talk a little bit about what what of that
was true when you were there?
Is any of it not true?
No, it's 100 percent true.
Amazon is completely off of metrics and numbers.
They calculate everything it is is actually
calculated down to the second you know, the
second you stop scanning the item, your time
accumulates time.
ALTEZ So I was a part of that machine.
I very much had to monitor my associates in
my department.
But like I said, I was just a supervisor that
related to them.
So they respected the fact that I wasn't that
type of supervisor.
That will be hard on them if they came back
from break or whatever the case may be, because
I know how massive these buildings are and
how the working conditions can take a toll
on your body.
Now, were you pressured even though you weren't
pressuring the pickers may be the way that
you would be expected to.
Did that cause a problem for you?
Absolutely, I mean, for the most part, it
caused a problem with my own personal career
growth because obviously management knew that
I would never side with them when it came
to certain things like that.
And I was kind of like the black sheep out
of the supervisors.
Everybody knew that I had a backbone and I
always spoke up for what was right.
And I always sided with the employees at entry
level because that's where I started from.
I never forgot where I came from and it didn't
bother me, but it definitely hindered my career
there.
You know, I applied for a salaried manager
position there forty nine times and I was
denied every last one of them.
And it's probably because the fact that they
knew that I would never be fully pro Amazon
were what reason were you given the forty
nine times why you weren't going to be given
the salaried manager.
Well, Wolf, for my own personal experiences,
it was it was basically bogus, a lot of the
interviews were set up for me to fail from
the beginning.
A lot of them the interviews, they already
knew who they wanted in those positions before
I even applied.
So it was a combination of a lot of different
things.
Also, there was, you know, letters and management
above me that didn't like me as a person,
you know, whatever the case may be.
So it was a lot of different things of why
I didn't get those positions.
And I believe it's systemic, you know, systemic
racism that exists inside and outside as well.
Over a million and a half employees worldwide
and only and then twenty six years of existence.
Only eight percent of the management is black
or brown.
So that just tells you right there, the higher
up the food chain, the less likely, you know,
you are to be colored.
So I even believe this for the first time
this past year, they have one black woman
that's on the senior team.
So that just tells you right there the chances
of me getting promoted up the ladder with
Slim and Chris.
I don't I'm not I'm not familiar with the
numbers you're citing.
So I'm curious, when you say eight percent,
is that globally or in the United States?
That's globally.
OK, do you know what it is in the United States?
I would guess it would be a lot less than
that.
You know, I'm pretty sure it's not too many
of us at the top.
You know, once again, in this this company's
twenty six or twenty seven years of existence
for the first time ever, they put one black
woman on the senior team, the team, they call
it.
So that just tells you right there they're
way behind the eight ball.
When it comes to diversity, when it comes
to management, were there ways in which working
at Amazon was better than when you did actual
customer facing retail like Wal-Mart and Target?
Of course, you know, I worked at competitors
and I worked during the holiday season.
And, you know, nothing's worse than working
Black Friday, right.
At a time when you got customers trying to
get their items in the lines of that, everything's
chaos, chaos.
So we're going to warehouse.
You have to deal with customers.
It's a benefit.
But once again, it's also calisthenics, you
know, so I used to tell my employees new hires,
you have a gym membership, you might want
to cancel it.
Now, ultimately, you were fired by Amazon.
Can you talk about why?
Yeah, absolutely, you know, last year, the
beginning of a pandemic, late February, early
March, when this virus came into the country
in Seattle, killing the senior citizens over
there.
I was afraid over here on the East Coast and
I tried to raise health and safety concerns
going through the proper channels.
And after doing that for a few weeks, I tried
organizing workers inside the warehouse, sitting
in the cafeteria 10 hours a day off the clock,
telling many, as many workers as I can.
And I learned in a meeting with my bosses
that we had cases in the facility and they
didn't want me to tell anybody not to cause
a panic or disrupt business.
So I felt that I had to take further action.
And after a whole week of advocating and pleading,
going back and forth with the general manager
of the building, they decided to quarantine
just me and everybody else.
And that didn't make sense to me, not even
the person I tried to work with, none of the
people in my department that was around the
person who was infected.
It was just me.
So I do.
They were using me as a target.
And as a result, I held a protest on March
30 outside of my facility.
And then two hours later, I was terminated
over the phone.
A week after that, Jeff Bezos and his top
general counsel, David Sapolsky, they tried
to run a smear campaign on me, calling me
not smart, articulate, and make me the whole
face of the whole unionization efforts.
So there's a couple of different things here,
right?
I mean, one is that the part about infections
at the facility and the other is trying to
organize the the the workers.
So let's talk about the first one first.
So you were told by managers not to talk about
the fact that there were infected employees?
Absolutely, yes.
On March 24, we had our Daily Sync meeting,
which we have every single day.
And that's pretty much given us the rundown
for the rest of the day and how we're supposed
to go.
But on that day, it was different.
That day they told us we had a case that was
actually two weeks prior for the first time,
and they pretty much told the supervisors
not to say anything.
And I just felt that was wrong.
I felt like I had to say something that took
my stance there.
That was the last day I work for Amazon.
So that was a supervisors meeting.
And you guys were told not to mention the
case to the employees you supervise?
Absolutely.
OK, and then separately, but around the same
time, you were working to organize the workers
there.
And what was the point of the organization
to approach management about virus related
matters or to collectively bargain on salary
and benefits?
Well, actually, that was the first time I
learned about it.
I haven't even started organizing yet.
That was March twenty four.
I what I was doing was behind the scenes,
I was sending out emails to the governor,
to Governor Cuomo office, to the CDC department
in our media outside and fight behind the
scenes.
It wasn't until after that meeting the next
day when I came back to the facility, I told
my supervisor I won't be working for the remainder
of the week.
And that's when I started to go in the cafeteria
and tell all the workers that I came in contact
with the truth that you we've been working
around somebody who tested positive from that
point forward.
What we did every morning, a small group of
us marched into the general manager's office
and voiced concerns.
Yeah, I has this thing called Voice of Associates.
We associate allowed to write on the board
their complaints.
So I said, you know what?
Here is your your voiceover associates board
right here in person.
Here's our complaint to be one of the building,
to just be simply closed down and sanitized,
we would have came back to work.
No problem.
And that's all we wanted in the beginning.
But obviously a lot more.
Now, what was officially given to you is the
reason why you were being let go.
They claim that I violated socially justice
policies that none of us ever read are ever
implemented as supervisor, I'm supposed to
receive the policy that relay that information
that I never did.
So they didn't exist because they didn't know
what we were dealing with know.
And that's all it was OK to understand that
they didn't know what they were dealing with,
how they handle it, but to ignore the fact
that workers were on the line to help allegations,
you know, mothers that were pregnant, parents
that had children at home, including myself,
were afraid to come to work and refuse to
listen to us.
That's a whole nother story.
When it comes to what you're fighting for
now, if I understand correctly, you're looking
to organize sort of a nonunion nationwide
group of workers.
Am I right that you're going the nonunion
approach and what made you decide to go about
it that way?
Mean, you know, I feel like with Amazon is
such a large entity, a large business, that
we actually would be kind of difficult for
one union to try to unionize the entire nation.
We're talking a hundred thousand workers.
So I felt like an organization that has a
worker ribbon committee would be more beneficial
for Amazon workers, something that's working
in employee controlled but union like structure.
You know, I feel like that's the best way
possible.
It's sort of like cutting out the middleman.
No, no union dues or whatever the case may
be.
But workers are allowed to sit in on negotiation,
negotiate their own contracts.
And then now we we also have enough power
workers power.
The Congress say you're a social worker and
you have to go to work in the middle of a
pandemic.
Right.
We're going to say, no, we're not going to
work until we have, you know, PPE provided
by the company, hazard pay, medical leave,
all these things that we're demanding before
we consider ourselves essential workers.
So that's interesting.
So absent that, actually, the actual union
with the dues, sort of like at what level
would you see this working?
Would it be at the individual facility level?
Would be at a regional level or how do you
how would you structure that?
Yeah, you know, I thought about it, and I
think regional would be better if you had
just one to break down the country into regions.
You have a committee, a workplace committee
that represents that region because we know
the cost of living in different parts of the
country is different of these committees.
Negotiate the contract and there you go.
That be able to, you know, take care of the
mass of the employees that work for Amazon.
What unionizing?
You have to do a facility by facility, and
that's going to be a longer process.
As you can see what they're doing in Alabama,
they prolonging it.
The union busting.
Yeah, they're firing workers.
They're hiring workers.
They're doing all these things to disrupt
it.
But if you have a workplace committee, that's
something that's built internally, it's going
to be hard to bust that up.
Did you ever see or experience or become aware
of sort of like not union busting, but maybe
union prevention activity by Amazon?
Absolutely, but as a supervisor, you know,
I watched those training videos, we had to
take tests, assessment tests, they try to
mix in certain questions that are obviously
related to union busting.
But I never applied them.
You know, like I said, I was I'm always on
the employee entry level position side, so
I never applied these things.
You know, obviously, there was management
that you applied that and they still do.
But, you know, you have to understand what
you're dealing with.
You're dealing with a company that does union
from the beginning.
And now we see that is very much necessary,
that they are unionized.
Yeah, I remember in my early days at Circuit
City, they sat me down and mixed in with training
videos about like how to use the sale systems
and what the process is for requesting time
off.
They throw in videos about, you know, we want
to maintain a direct relationship with employees.
We don't want any intermediaries or middlemen.
And it was very it was very sophisticated,
in fact, the way that it was done.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, the same thing.
You know, they mix in the questions like safety
and hazmat and all this training.
I'm like, well, you know, you read between
the lines, right?
Yeah.
We've been speaking with Chris Smalls, former
Amazon employee, now a leader of the E Commerce
labor rights movement.
Chris, I really appreciate your time.
And we're going to continue following your
great work.
Absolutely.
I appreciate you guys share my story.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.